TICK-TOCK.
FIRST TONIGHT'S MONDAY BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
IN 2016 CANDIDATE TRUMP PROMISED
TO RESHAPE THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT?
HE WANTED TO PUT ON PEOPLE THAT
WERE ORIGINAL AND
CONSTITUTIONALISTS.
NOT PEOPLE THAT LEGISLATE FROM
THE BENCH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FULFILLED
ANOTHER CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
JUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH IS THE
NEWEST MEMBER OF THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
A LIFETIME APPOINTMENT MAKING
HIM THE SECOND JUDGE SENT TO
THIS BENCH BY THE PRESIDENT.
DON'T DURING HIS SWEARING IN,
THE PRESIDENT CONGRATULATED
JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND APOLOGIZEDED
FOR THE HORRIFIC NOMINATION
PROCESS WE WITNESSED FOR 3
STRAIGHT WEEKS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON BEHALF OF OUR NATION, I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO BRETT AND
THE ENTIRE KAVANAUGH FAMILY FOR
THE TERRIBLE PAIN AND SUFFERING
YOU HAVE BEEN FORCED TO ENDURE.
THOSE WHO STEPPED FORWARD TO
SERVE OUR COUNTRY DESERVE A FAIR
AND DIGNIFIED EVALUATION.
NOT A CAMPAIGN OF POLITICAL AND
PERSONAL DESTRUCTION BASED ON
LIES AND DECEPTION.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE KAVANAUGH
FAMILY VALLEYS VIOLATES DUE
PROCESS.
A MAN OR WOMAN MUST BE
PREASSUMED INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY.
>> Sean: JUDGE KAVANAUGH SAID
THIS.
>> ARTICLE 3 OF THE CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES THAT THE JUDICIAL POWER
SHALL BE VESTED IN ONE SUPREME
COURT.
THE SUPREME COURT IS AN
INSTITUTION OF LAW.
IT IS NOT A PARTISAN OR
POLITICAL INSTITUTION.
THE JUSTICES DO NOT SIT ON
OPPOSITES SIDE OF AN AISLE.
WE DON'T CAUCUS IN SEPARATE
ROOMS.
THE SUPREME COURT IS A TEAM OF 9
AND I WILL ALWAYS BE A TEAM
PLAYER ON THE TEAM OF NINE.
I WAS NOT APPOINTED TO SERVE ONE
PARTY OR ONE INTEREST, BUT TO
SERVE ONE NATION.
AMERICA'S CONSTITUTIONAL LAWS
PROTECT EVERY PERSON OF EVERY
BELIEF AND EVERY BACKGROUND.
EVERY LITIGANT IN THE SUPREME
COURT CAN BE ASSURED I WILL
LISTEN TO THEIR ARGUMENTS WITH
RESPECT AND AN OPEN MIND.
>> Sean: IN THE FACE OF ONE OF
THE MOST DISGUSTING POLITICAL
HIT JOBS, JUDGE KAVANAUGH MADE
HISTORY.
FROM THE BEGINNING THE DAY THAT
JUSTICE KENNEDY ANNOUNCED HIS
RETIREMENT ON THIS PROGRAM, I
WARNED YOU ALL OF THIS WOULD
HAPPEN.
TONIGHT WE BEGIN THANKS TO ALL
OF YOU.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF MY 23rd
CONSECUTIVE YEAR ON THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL.
WE HAVE CHRONICLED ALL OF THIS
FOR YOU.
IT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PLAYBOOK.
WE GET THIS ALL THE TIME.
BORK AND THOMAS AND THEY DID IT
TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND HIS WIFE
AND FAMILY.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER.
THE LEFT WILL STOP AT NOTHING
WHEN IT COMES TO BLOCKING A
NOMINATION.
DEMOCRATS OPENLY ACCUSING
KAVANAUGH OF GANG RAPE AND
DRUGGING TEENAGE GIRLS ON A
REGULAR WEEKEND BASIS.
CALLING HIM EVIL.
COMPARING HIM TO BILL COSBY AND
SO MUCH MORE.
WITH ZERO CORROBORATING EVIDENCE
AND ZERO CORROBORATING
WITNESSES.
BASED ON 4-DECADES OLD CLAIMS
WITH HOLES ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THIS KIND OF GUILT BY ACCUSATION
WAS PARROTED BY THE SO-CALLED
NEWS MEDIA INCLUDING THE
LATE-NIGHT SO-CALLED COMEDIAN
WITH THE FAR LEFT HOLIER THAN
NOW.
OVER THE WEEKEND A WRITER FROM A
SHOW TWEETED THIS:
I AM GLAD WE RUINED BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S LIFE.
STAND BACK AND THINK HOW UGLY
AND DESPICABLE THAT.
SHE LATER APOLOGIZED.
NOTHING FUNNY.
THAT TWEET SUMS UP WHAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED NOW FOR FAR TOO MANY
ELECTIONS AND CONFIRMATIONS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S ALL THEY OFFER YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN 29 DAYS.
THE POLITICS OF PERSONAL
DESTRUCTION.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
THEY WANT TO REGAIN POWER AND
THEY TRY TO MAKE CONSERVATIVES
AS EVIL AS YOU CAN.
THEY ARE NOT TAKING THE
KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION WELL.
THIS IS A SHOCKER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS THE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF
TRIBUNALISM.
>> PEOPLE ARE SHRIEKING AND
SAYING DON'T SEND US BACK TO THE
'50s.
BRETT KAVANAUGH SAID YES I CAN.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS FOR LAW AND
ORDER BUT NOT FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE.
>> THIS IS A CRUSHING DEFEAT FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
>> TRUMP DELIVERED RACISM FOR
THESE PEOPLE AND MISOGYNY AND
NOW THE SUPREME COURT FOR THESE
PEOPLE.
WE WILL SEE IF THIS REIN THEY
HAVE CONTROL OVER ALL 3 BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT IF THIS LASTS FOR
30 DAYS OR 2 YEARS OR 1,000
YEARS.
>> Sean: SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS
ISSUED A HISTORIC ADDRESS AND
CAST THE DECIDING VOTE TO SEND
JUDGE KAVANAUGH TO THE BENCH.
SHE AND HER STAFF ARE RECEIVING
RAPE THREATS AND DEATH THREATS.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SAID WHITE
PEOPLE COME GET YOUR PEOPLE.
SLAMMING COLLINS AND ANY WOMAN
WHO SUPPORTED KAVANAUGH.
CALLING THEM GENDER TRAITORS.
AT NBC NEWS:
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION
IS THE ULTIMATE AFFIRMATION OF
THE PATRIARCHY.
REALLY?
SHE IS HELPING ORGANIZE THE
WOMEN'S MARCH AND INTRODUCED
SENATOR GILLIBRAND OF NEW YORK
AT AN ANTI-KAVANAUGH PROTEST.
SHE SAID SUSAN COLLINS WAS A
TRAITOR TO WOMEN.
CANCEL KAVANAUGH #.
DEVOID OF ANY NEW IDEAS TO HELP
IMPROVE OUR COUNTRY.
MAKE US MORE SECURE.
MORE PROSPEROUS.
LOOK AT WHAT DEMOCRATS DO.
THEY DIVIDE AMERICANS.
THIS IS WHAT IDENTITY POLITICS
IT.
EVERY 2 YEARS, EVERY 4 YEARS,
YOU WATCH ELECTIONS.
WHAT DO LIBERALS DO?
THEY CALL REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVES RACIST, SEXIST.
MISOGYNY, THEY WANT DIRTY AND
AIR WATER.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO TAKE GRANDMA
IN A WHEELCHAIR AND THROW HER
OVER A CLIFF AND KILL CHILDREN.
DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR.
IT WE HAVE CHRONICLED A HISTORY
OF CHARACTER SLANDER BY THE LEFT
FOR THE 23 YEAR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MANY REPUBLICANS TALK IN
CODED RACIAL LANGUAGE ABOUT
TAKERS AND LOSERS.
THEY DEMONIZE PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND ENCOURAGED THE UGLY
AND ENCOURAGED THE UGIEST
IMPULLSES OF FRINGE.
>> IF YOU ACCEPT THE SUPPORT OF
KLAN SYMPATHIZERS BEFORE YOU
WILL ACCEPT THEIR SUPPORT AFTER
YOU ARE PRESIDENT.
>> UNCHAIN WALL STREET.
>> [BOOING].
>> THEY WILL PUT Y'ALL BACK IN
CHAINS.
>> THE LEADER THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND CONGRESS, IT'S WRONG
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
BLOCK AN ACCURATE SEN US.
-- CENSUS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO COUNT
EVERYONE THEY CAN'T COUNT ON.
>> THEY ARE IF FAVOR OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IF YOU CAN
DUNK THE BASKETBALL OR SINK A
3-POINT SHOT.
THEY ARE NOT IN FAVOR IF YOU
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE A
LEADER IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
DON'T TELL ME WE HAVE A
COLORBLIND SOCIETY.
>> IN 1998 IN TEXAS MY FATHER
WAS KILLED.
BEATEN AND CHAINED BECAUSE HE
WAS BLACK.
WHICH GOVERNOR BUSH REFUSED HATE
CRIME LEGISLATION IT WAS LIKE MY
FATHER WAS KILLED ALL OVER
AGAIN.
>> WHEN YOU DON'T VOTE, YOU LET
ANOTHER CHURCH EXPLODE.
YOU ALLOW ANOTHER CROSS TO BURN.
>> ♪ ♪
>> YOU HAVE THEIR PLAN.
LET'S HAVE DIRTIER AIR AND
WATER.
LESS PEOPLE WITH HEALTH
INSURANCE.
>> Sean: HE DON'T MAKE THIS UP.
TONIGHT THE STAKES COULD NOT BE
HIGHER.
IN 29 DAYS, IF WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE REWARD THIS PARTY, WITH
THESE DISGUSTING TACTICS WE KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
I HAVE WARNED YOU THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY DOESN'T HAVE A PLAN TO
MAKE YOUR LIFE BETTER.
THEY ARE DESTROY TRUMP EVERY
SECOND, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
THEY WANT IMPEACHMENT AND OPEN
BORDERS AND GET RID OF ICE AND
KEEP OBAMACARE.
REMEMBER THE TAX CUTS THAT
CREATED 4 MILLION JOBS, THEY
WANT THEIR CRUMBS BACK.
DON'T TAKE "HANNITY"'S WORD.
LISTEN FOR YOURSELF.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO IN 29 DAYS.
IF WE ARE STUPID ENOUGH TO GIVE
THEM BACK POWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MAXINE WATERS DON'T SAY
IMPEACHMENT ANYMORE.
AND I SAY IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT!
>> IN TERMS OF THE BONUS THAT
CORPORATE AMERICA RECEIVED
VERSUS THE CRUMBS THAT THEY ARE
GIVING TO WORKERS TO PUT THE
SCHMOOZE ON, IT'S PATHETIC.
>> THEY SHOULD ONCE AND FOR ALL
WORK WITH US TO IMPROVE THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND RENOUNCE
REPEAL AS WELL.
>> WE HAVE TO REEXAMINE ICE AND
ITS ROLE AND THE WORK IT IS
DOING AND START FROM SCRATCH.
>> WE SHOULD PROTECT FAMILIES
THAT NEED OUR HELP.
THAT'S NOT WHAT ICE IS DOING.
GET RID OF IT AND START OVER.
REIMAGINE IT.
>> Sean: 29 DAYS TO GO UNTIL THE
MOST IMPORTANT MID-TERMS IN OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
THE FATE OF THE COUNTRY IS
RESTING IN YOUR HANDS.
WE HAVE THE POWER.
LET'S SET THE STAGE.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THE PARTY THAT CONTROLS THE
PRESIDENCY GAINED SEATS IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES ONLY 3
TIMES IN THE LAST 100 YEARS.
LAST TIME WAS IN 2002 AFTER
9-11.
THE STAKES HAVE NEVER BEEN THIS
HIGH.
WILL YOU REWARD THESE DISGUSTING
TACTICS FROM A PARTY THAT HAS NO
PLAN TO MAKE YOUR LIFE BETTER?
OR WILL YOU ASK YOURSELF THIS
SIMPLE QUESTION:
IS AMERICA BETTER OFF THAN WE
WERE 2 YEARS AGO?
IS THE COUNTRY BETTER OFF?
IS AMERICA STRONGER?
IS AMERICA SAFER?
IS THE ECONOMY DOING BETTER?
IS THE PRESIDENT KEEPING
PROMISES THAT HE MADE TO YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THE ANSWER TO THOSE QUESTIONS --
YOU WILL NEVER SEE THIS ON ANY
OTHER SHOW.
THE ANSWER IS RIGHT THERE.
OVERWHELMING SUCCESS!
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE DROPPED TO
ITS LOWEST LEVEL IN NEARLY 50
YEARS.
1969 THE METS WON THE WORLD
SERIES.
HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT IN AMERICA
ALL TIME LOW AND FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
ASIAN-AMERICANS.
WOMEN IN THE WORK FORCE.
YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
IN 14 STATES OUT OF OUR 50
STATES.
MANUFACTURING.
CONFIDENCE AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
400,000 NEW MANUFACTURING JOBS
BROUGHT BACK TO AMERICA.
JOBS OBAMA SAID WERE NEVER
COMING BACK.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE ALL TIME
HIGH.
4 MILLION FEWER PEOPLE ON FOOD
STAMPS THAN 2 YEARS AGO.
8 MILLION PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY
IN 2 YEARS.
3 TRILLION DOLLARS SPENT ON
SURING OUR BORDERS AND BUILDING
THE WALL.
THE PRESIDENT KEPT HIS PROMISE
ON NAFTA AND PULLED US OUT OF
THE IRANIAN DEAL AND THE
PROGRESS GOING ON NOW.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN A MISSILE FROM
ROCKET MAN SINCE DECEMBER LAST
YEAR.
THE PRESIDENT MAKING PROGRESS.
WE MIGHT HAVE DENUCLEARIZATION
OF THE ENTIRE PENINSULA IN
KOREA.
NEW PIPELINES OPENED UP.
THAT'S AMERICAN JOBS.
THE AMERICAN ENERGY SECTOR
BOOMING.
COAL MINERS JOBBED SAVE IN WEST
VIRGINIA.
WE HAVE PROMISES MADE AND KEPT.A
WE HAVE PROMISES MADE AND KEPT.N
WE HAVE PROMISES MADE AND KEPT.W
WE HAVE PROMISES MADE AND KEPT.
VIRGINIA.
TONIGHT THAT AGENDA 29 DAYS FROM
NOW IS IN JEOPARDY.
OUR BOOMING ECONOMY IN JEOPARDY.
YOU LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE HOUSE
DISTRICTS THAT YOU SEE IN YELLOW
ON YOUR SCREEN, LOOK CLOSELY.
THOSE DISTRICTS WILL DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT NANCY PELOSI WILL
BECOME THE NEXT SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
PELOSI IS MEASURING THE DRAPE
ASKS PLANNING ON ENDLESS
INVESTIGATION AFTER
INVESTIGATION.
EVEN INTO THE NEWLY APPOINTED
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
KAVANAUGH.
SORE LOSER.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS THE HOUSE IS
PLANING TO GO AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY ARE ON A QUEST.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH THIS
PRESIDENT.
IF YOU LIVE IN ONE OF THESE
STATES, YOU WILL DECIDE THE
FUTURE OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
LOOK HOW CLOSE THE VOTE WAS THIS
WEEKEND.
YOU LIVE IN NORTH DAKOTA.
HEIDI HEITKAMP SHE GAVE INTO THE
DEMOCRATIC MOB AND VOTED AGAINST
JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND SO DID
DONNELLY IN INDIANA AND ALL OF
THESE DEMOCRATS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF 1:
JOE MANCHIN OF WEST VIRGINIA.
THERE ARE NO MORE MODERATES LEFT
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THERE IS NO DIVERSITY OF
OPINION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY EVOLVED
INTO THE PARTY OF THE RADICAL
FAR LEFT AND NOT THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WITH JOBS AND SECURITY.
IT'S A PARTY THAT HAS PROVEN IN
THE LAST 3 WEEKS THAT THEY HAVE
A DISDAIN EVEN FOR OUR U.S.
CONSTITUTION WHICH SHOULD BE
NONPARTISAN WHICH WE ALL LOVE.
DUE PROCESS AND THE PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE.
THEY ARE THE PARTY OF SMEARS,
LIES AND BUDGEONING.
THE PARTY OF IDENTITY POLITICS.
IN 29 DAYS, EVERY AMERICAN IN
EVERY CORNER OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY, YOU HAVE TO RISE UP AND
SEND A MESSAGE.
DEMOCRATS THEIR BRAND OF
RUTHLESS POLITICS, YOU CAN'T
REWARD PEOPLE FOR WHAT THEY DO
EVERY 2 AND 4 YEARS.
DHA SHEA HAVE DONE THE LAST 3
WEEKS.
IF YOU DON'T GET TO THE POLLS
AND VOTE, CORE PRINCIPLES ARE AT